guys tell me who you are and what you're
doing here today I iron fists from
Marvel Comics and this is fantastic
excellent thing unfortunately can't
speak can you for yourself at the moment
no exactly so we're going to be speaking
to you through iron fist it's like okay
fantastic right well guys this is the
first time that you've donned these
costumes or is this something that you
use all the time it's the first time
I've worn this one it was only
completely last night and this has been
this was debuted in February at the
London Super Comic Con it's been to a
couple of events so far it's holding up
pretty well so far and do you go to a
lot of these kind of comic about events
we do know we started in July last year
it was just a friend of ours are sitting
down so we thought we'd take him to an
ADIZ event to be dressed up fun it turns
out there's a whole underground culture
of cosplayers and people that enjoy this
sort of thing so you got into it now
have you very much so yes it's both it's
a full-time hobby aliases I mean that
costumes for took several months to
construct pretty both pretty impressive
I mean there's a lot of work that's gone
into both and hasn't it tell us a little
bit about how you go about putting them
together oh we've all starts with
concept sketches which are already laid
out for us by the comic artists so that
part's very simple but this is built
entirely from upholestry fun every piece
is carved individually and it's very
squishy it doesn't look it but it's
covered in a layer of latex and then
painted by our master artist here yeah
so it's all hand carved and painted over
a very very long period of months how
are you enjoying the costumes today are
you finding me getting a lot of love for
them our costumes we're getting thing
always gets a lot of love that thing
hugs are becoming a regular at events
now well we haven't seen too many
cosplayers so far but it's still early
we know there's a lot more coming and
it's gonna be a lot more to them
tomorrow but so far it's the lonely days
exactly what you're looking forward to
while you're at the Kapow comic
convention it's the cosplay that we come
for it's when we when we were little we
wanted photos with us our favorite
superheroes so I don't see why people
shouldn't carry on that tradition for
the next generations brilliant well good
luck guys enjoy the rest of Kapow and
made lots of people want their photos
taken with you I'm sure they will
you